secretary of state anthony blinken is
heading to the persian gulf nation of
qatar this weekend that's where
thousands of afghan refugees have been
taken and where concerns remain high
over the taliban's return to power in
afghanistan blinken says the u.s is in
constant contact with more than 100
americans who are still there the biden
administration says it plans to admit
about 50 000 afghan refugees to the
united states but the process to leave
afghanistan is complicated and full of
twists and turns even for people with
dual citizenship christina raffini
reports on one couple's ordeal
onai payam and her husband farid both
american citizens were only supposed to
be in kabul for four days that's you
that's me screaming
one last trip to see family and
celebrate his brother's wedding before
the taliban took control on sunday early
in the morning when i woke up i saw one
of my family members burning some
documents at the backyard
that's when i
thought that everything is done it's
over now they're in
the trip turned into an urgent
evacuation they registered with the
state department and tried to get to the
airport but crowds of desperate afghans
some with visas most without blocked
access to the gate we couldn't get in
and
that's when we decided to go back and
just wait
just to wait for a better plan
the plan came with help from friends in
the u.s who got them a contact inside
the airport they tried again this time
at night what is the level of anxiety
you feel
rolling up to a taliban checkpoint you
stop breathing at that moment when you
see them thinking okay they know who i
am and they are going to take me
but they let you go and they let me go
and after a few tense minutes on the
wrong side of the barbed wire
they were taken inside to wait i had to
wait for like more than 24 hours did you
tell them you were american citizens i
did a couple of times and i was being
told that everyone is the same here
when she finally did get an evacuation
flight through uzbekistan her husband
farid decided to stay behind and help
others get out well i had a family there
i had
people i worked with and i couldn't
really leave them behind we both were in
state of
survivor's guilt thinking why
was i the privileged one
who managed to get in where there were
women with their small kids screaming
for help
infants left
unattended
small kids left unattended there
did you see these kids at the airport
yeah
were there a lot of them there were a
lot of them
with her own three children anxiously
waiting onai spent almost a week in
transit back to virginia farid who got a
more direct flight three days later was
there to welcome her i know
your family is afghan you grew up there
but did this experience at all make you
feel more american yes because the way i
was received here
as someone i belong
belonged to
and
the way they took care of me
everyone the soldiers the friends
the community itself
when you came home you felt like this is
your home this is my home
for cbs this morning saturday christina
raffini vienna virginia
you know that's just one story there are
so many others and there are still
people that are working
literally around the clock to try to
help those that are trying to get out be
it u.s citizen canadian citizen or
afghans that helped
in the u.s the reality is that so many
people that have been left behind will
have to remain behind and we'll have to
deal with this new power structure for
those who have left imagine growing up
somewhere and then yeah and realizing